yesterday we interviewed my former
economics professor Richard wolf and
yesterday I also learned about professor
watchlist dot-org which is a website
that lists nearly 200 professors which
this right-wing site says represent the
threat to academic freedom and are
trying to advance a radical agenda in
lecture halls and two of the professor's
listed are professors of mine former
professors of mine number one is of
course Richard Wolff he most recently
taught at UMass in 2008 and since
retired from UMass and is a visiting
professor at the new school in New York
City professor of mine guest on the show
and also listed on professor watch list
is such jolly the founder and executive
director of the media education
foundation where I interned when I was I
think a junior at UMass Amherst also a
communications professor at the
University of Massachusetts Amherst who
I had for three or four classes and
someone I know personally and someone
who has also been on the show before
they are listed along with about 198
other professors at professor watch list
org this was developed by turning-point
USA which is an organization it's always
funny to tell you what they claim they
do they say that they promote the
principles of free markets and limited
government on college campuses and at
high school so let's break this down
step by step I didn't ask professor
Wolff about this yesterday because I
didn't know about it I saw this
afterwards he was interviewed about it
and he said he's not fazed by being put
on the list and that it's just a
misunderstanding of what the job of our
educational system is meant to be such
jolly says that what the the explanation
of why such jolly is on the list says
that he is infamous for his politically
loaded Twitter account and this is super
weird because I found two Twitter
accounts for suk-ja Lee one is just
called set jolly and the other one is
called set jolly UMass one has no post
since 2014 and the other has no post
since June if you're gonna critique
someone Pat for a radically loaded
Twitter account you would hope to see
that they've posted at least more than
in the last five months right yeah I
would say so I mean these sort of black
lists who are kind of explaining why
sales of the book 1984 yeah been so up
in the past few years - no doubt about
it and yeah I mean as far as sult is
concerned set is very anti-israeli I've
never agreed with him on that issue but
to say that he is a radical that needs
to be watched I don't know I don't know
about that it seems like a bit much and
UMass spokesman Edie blag uzuki who I
also know from my time at UMass put out
a statement saying that the that
University of Massachusetts expresses
support for freedom of speech and
continued debate in the classrooms from
various perspective I think that's the
right approach that schools should take
to this right well how do we know that
you're not just the product of their
radicalism right I mean we had Richard
wolf on the show as you said yesterday
and I mean I'm still trying to recover
from the indoctrination it was tough I
would say that the fact that I disagree
would set about a lot of what he teaches
in the classes and the fact that even
though I find the Marxist analysis that
Richard Wolff does of society
fascinating and valuable I still
consider myself a capitalist who was
into democratic socialism I think our
evidence that I was not overwhelmed by
the propaganda if anything you were just
taught to tea to think critically which
is which is important out of college I
think that that's exactly right and the
professor watchlist website says they're
going to continue to fight for free
speech and the right for professors to
say what they want but that everybody
students parents alumni needs to know
incidents and names of professors that
are advancing radical agendas I really
don't see how Richard Wolffe is radical
I mean unless you feel genuinely
threatened by the fact that he's doing a
critique of capitalist economics through
a Marxist lens
yes that's what he's doing now if you
don't feel threatened by that I don't
know why you would call it radical if
you don't think there's anything there
then there's no reason to see someone
who represents such a tiny percentage of
economists who actually takes the time
to do a serious analysis from an
alternative to capitalism you would only
see that as radical if you actually see
it as a threat and I bet there are
radical professors on this list
we've talked about radical professors
before the question is number one if the
list isn't accurate is it of any value
number two because much of this is
subjective could the list possibly be
accurate and number three is this the
type of list that makes sense to have or
does this reek of a sort of McCarthyism
of sorts and I think that it does
whether or not there are individual
radicals on this list radicalism is
mostly in the eye of the beholder and
when we create such a list what are we
suggesting should happen to these
professors because they say Pat we
support professors doing what they want
but people should be aware about radical
agenda as well they should be aware of
it
to what end in order to do what to these
professors and I don't know what the
answer is it also seems like the term
that they use radical seems to imply
that there's some sort of violence that
they're encouraging to yeah is of course
not the case that's always an undertone
when you accuse of radicalism it's
always a question of what do you really
mean by that are you talking about ideas
are you saying these are ideas that
could move into real-world action or
what exactly are you saying
anyway Richard Wolfe and such Olli
genuinely nice people that I really like
and fascinating that they both are on
this list
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed comm slash TDPS I don't really
like going into glasses stores and
trying on glasses while the salesperson
sort of hovers over me and I like more
than 30 seconds to actually figure out
whether I like the glasses so with the
Warby Parker home Tryon I was able to
pick five pairs that I liked put them on
in the comfort of my own home pick the
one I liked the most and then Warby
Parker put my prescription lenses in
there for me a lot of people don't know
that the eyeglass industry is controlled
by just a few big corporations that keep
prices very high like three hundred
dollars
for prescription glasses hi which is
just insane Warby Parker glasses start
at $95 that's what mine cost and for
every pair of glasses sold Warby Parker
distributes a pair of glasses to someone
in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing